Oi e aí galera que assiste meu canal
tudo bom com vocês ou com o vídeo do
está dada bem
acabei de acordar depois eu tô com sua
cara destruída porque eu tô na rotina
muito louca tá coçando meu olho só acho
que eu tô conseguindo e sinusite olha
tristeza parece um bebo eu queria pedir
para você que faz parte da tropilha que
não desiste do vida da tropilha da
madrugada que foi esquecida que se
dependesse do vendo a Tropa da madrugada
estava sem dormir já sei lá uma semana
espera eu quero continuar como academia
tá ligado que tipo aciente paga academia
Vai um beijo não vai mais eu quero
continuar tipo academia quando você
força para continuar eu não quero ter
parado de fazer esses dias e achar que
eu não consigo mas eu também preciso da
ajuda de vocês porque os vedas tão
flopado meme
bebendo 30 mil lycra eu vim 30 mil likes
eu tava um plano de querer levar para
Europa para mostrar para vocês como é
que meus reais fora do Brasil porque tem
outras paradas a roda que esse trambolho
mal do mundo aqui tá vendo esses dois
iguais aqui meu lado tá bonito que eu
achei esse entanto consegui ficar
trocando de mão não é só da esquerda
mesmo eu fiquei assim tipo então vou
fazer o seguinte eu vou correr atrás de
todos esses vezes atrasados nem que eu
sou de tipo três vídeos no dia mas eu
vou correr atrás eu quero também levar
para Europa parar de mostrar tudo vai
que funciona mais é como eu falei eu
preciso que a gente tenha montado uma
comunidade entendeu para poder fazer
valer a pena sabe que que eu tô
conversando ali De repente levar até um
de vocês de repente do sei né então fica
ligado esse link no Twitter se você viu
no Instagram vai lá no Twitter que você
viu do Facebook vai lá no Twitter onde
eu postei este vídeo aqui com o nome
porque os vendas estão atrasados DRT
pode criar essa comunidade desenhar não
tenho cliente crio Twitter vai lá TRT E
qual é o motivo mesmo cara a voz eu
tenho uma diabo da rede com a sinusite
atacada demais garganta quando eu viajo
assim sabe tá E aí ataca sinusite logo
passo para garganta ela tava fazendo
show quarta quinta sexta sábado e
domingo eu grito muito durante o show aí
segunda e terça então eu descanso eu fui
fazer publicidade São Paulo viajar 91
[Música]
E aí
um
[Música]
dois três e
E aí
e para depois gravar um clipe gravando o
melhor dia para o olho
melhor de usar honra do nosso indica
mais fácil não bota aí
tá bom
[Música]
agora
eu indico o melhor dia oito do Barone ai
pai para que os vídeos não saíram mas eu
gravei muita coisa durante esses dias
então quê que eu vou fazer eu vou vir
para cá fazer como se fosse um blog
Zinho igual esse que tá aparecendo
falando sobre que tava parecendo coisa
que eu filmei explicando para vocês e aí
você assistir como se fosse um blog
Zinho é por prestar atenção na minha
vida com vídeos que eu grave pode ser
vou chamar a varal para editar esse
vídeo e eu quero uma meta de 100.000
likes nesse vídeo aqui vamos nessa
clique em gostei aí e comenta embaixo
que você tava gostando Muita gente me
mandou mensagem cara tava virando meu
dia a dia tudo para dar um Parei vou
insistir igual academia e se vocês
entrar na minha mesma onda que eu levo a
camisinha para todo lugar do mundo
mostrando a última tudo bem da gente
tamo junto é nóis beijão tá e ter dois
quer ser meu amigo